okay I know I said I was done talking
about this kind of stuff for a while but
I guess much like with the doctor
himself the council
lies so at the end of the video I made
about Bill I did say that if anything
happened in the comments that spurred on
a whole new train of thought in a
similar direction that I probably would
be back with another video and here we
are now this one's going to be a bit
more free flowing than my thoughts were
on when I did my overview of political
messaging in who or addressing the
belief uh that bill is an agenda pushing
companion I went into both of those with
a goal kind of an end conclusion that I
knew I was building towards this one I
don't have a grander plan but I still
kind of want to talk about it so the
reason I want to talk about one Captain
Jack Harkness is because I saw
discussions of him come up a fair amount
in my video about Bill and also actually
a bit in videos before that but it came
out more there now I wasn't surprised by
this because really prior to Bill he was
kind of the standard Bearer for
characters who weren't 100% heterosexual
he was the first now over time there
were more there was Jenny and vastra we
had a couple of various Side characters
uh and so forth but really he was sort
of the go to example of that sort of
thing in the show for quite a while now
there were a number of commenters on
that video about Bill who posited the
question why are people okay with Jack
but not okay with Bill now some people
seem to be asking asking this question
in kind of a backhanded way implying or
some just outright saying I think Jack
did it better than Bill did and others
seem to be asking it with utter
sincerity saying you know why why is
everyone fine with Jack and not with
Bill and I have to assume that the ones
asking in sincerity are either newer
viewers or younger viewers and I'm not
saying that like in some sort of
patronizing pulling rank way like I've
been watching longer than you therefore
my opinion counts for more I just mean
that I have to assume they weren't
around when Jack was a little more fresh
and new because if they were they've got
real selective memories now full
disclosure I'm myself was not watching
back when series 1 aired so I was not on
the ground floor when Jack himself got
introduced I got into the show during
Series 3 and I didn't start watching it
as it aired until series 4 but pretty
much at that point I immediately looked
into forums and other online venues to
talk about it because I didn't have any
friends in person who were watching it
at that point so I had no one else to
talk to about it and the character of
Jack back then was not nearly as
universally loved as people seem to be
remembering right now or at least not
from what I saw now part of the reason I
was reluctant to talk about this before
is is unfortunately it's hard for me to
back up with hard data a lot of the
forums that I was on at the time
actually don't even exist anymore and
there's a limit to how far I'm
personally willing to dig through things
like old Reddit post and whatnot to try
and find support for this so if you're
going to just choose to not believe me I
don't I don't know what to tell you but
my memory is certainly that at the time
a lot of people were making the same
complaints about Jack then that they
make about Bill now he was called a
token character and agenda pushing
character people bemon how frequently
his sexuality was brought up and the
fact that he was willing to bang
anything there was an interesting stripe
of fan that actually seemed to get
really annoyed that his preferences were
leaning much more frequently towards men
specifically by the time Torchwood was a
few seasons in and so it's all very
baffling to me that people are now going
Jack was the way it should have been
done Bill's doing it wrong and why I
tend to think people asking that
question or expressing some of those
sentiments must be newer fans to the
show because what I will grant is nobody
complains about Jack for those reasons
now they did then but they don't anymore
so why did it stop I mean the character
didn't change he was always highly
sexual from the beginning and he
remained so so what changed honestly I
think just the passage of time at this
point fans have distance from Jack to be
able to look at him without as much raw
visceral emotion of living in the moment
with him and Jack's been off the show
for a while he has not been he has not
had an appearance since the David Tenant
specials now Torchwood did go on a
little bit longer after that but anyone
who was watching Torchwood presumably
was completely okay with Jack as a
character since it was basically his
show and not everyone who watched Doctor
Who does watch Torchwood so Jack has not
appeared on the main show in coming up
on 8 years now why is that important
well the kinds of things that the
tractors said at the time were going to
happen as a result of the introduction
of a character like Jack harness didn't
happen what am I talking about well at
the time certain Stripes of fans said
the same thing about Jack that they now
say about the casting of jod Whitaker
and the character of Bill what's next is
the ttis going to be rainbow patterned
and the Sonic Screwdriver is going to be
a tampon that dispenses condoms it was
all fairly standard slippery slope stuff
and slippery slope is almost always a
fallacy and even when it's not a logical
fallacy I find it to be a very cowardly
argument because you're basically hiding
behind something that doesn't exist so
you're trying to make an argument
against something but you won't actually
take a stance against that thing in
instead you're taking a stance against
the theoretical worst thing that will
result later which allows you this weird
thing of denouncing something now
without actually standing your ground
and denouncing it in and of itself
and unless you can site existing
precedent to actually show how the thing
you're saying will actually lead to the
next step you're claiming then it's just
a deceitful argument and in the case of
Jack time proved that that was not the
case the introduction of a
non-heterosexual character into the
world of Doctor Who Was Not step one in
it becoming rainbow gay time in the
Tardis where all the chairs are shaped
like dildos and the time Vortex is
patterned like the pride flag and once
it became clear again through the sheer
passage of time that that didn't happen
and his introduction was not step one in
that happening people backed off those
criticisms cuz they became silly and I
think that with the benefit of time the
same's going to end up being true about
Bill and the same's going to end up
being true of jod Whitaker playing the
doctor and I suppose if I am going to
reach some kind of conclusion with this
is that it's frustrating how many people
claim to not actually be railing against
Bill or against jod Whitaker but instead
against the theoretical worst thing that
happens later and look I do understand
the fear that results if you believe
something that you love is headed in a
direction that you don't like I am on
record at the beginning of this year
saying I thought Wonder Woman was going
to be terrible because of what had come
out of the dceu up to that point but you
know what I was wrong and delighted to
be wrong as fans we don't have to be
okay with everything that happens we do
however have to try and be cautious
about condemning an actor Creator writer
or character for what they're doing now
because of what we're afraid they're
going to do later and I'm not saying
you're not allowed to have those fears
but you can't beat somebody down with an
anger generated more about something
that they haven't done yet than it is
about what they've actually done because
all of the people who said that Jack
Harkness was the death nail of Doctor
Who they look pretty silly now and for
my money so will the people being so
viciously venomously against Bill or jod
whak as the doctor caution is one thing
skepticism is healthy but preemptive
anger that can be hazardous that can be
Flatout toxic and I say this recognizing
that this is something I myself have
been guilty of in the past and if I'm
being completely honest I probably will
again I'm human I do get wrapped up in
emotions but what I'm going to try
really hard to do is be more fair to
things that have not actually come out
yet at least in terms of my anger level
I'm not promising I'm not still going to
be a skeptical grumpy I think this is
going to stink bastard I'm just talking
about the vitriol uh and also if and
when these things come out and do in
fact suck yeah I I will get angry about
that but there's no need to try and
cross that bridge before the darn
thing's even been built and on that
awkwardly worded metaphor I think we'll
wrap things up so what are your thoughts
on looking back at the ition to Captain
Jack Harkness or about anything else
that I have said please keep it civil
and as best as you can it's what I'm
trying to do these days in any case
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
counil of geese Give a listen to the
Council of Geeks podcast I also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast
available on fire andwater podcast.com
and on the fire andwater network podcast
feed and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]